starting up in five four three two one
what's crackin you sexy sexy unassured
[ __ ] don't know what you're doing what
your life just like me people I love you
so much
there's an episode of genius brain
podcast we have the very sexy
the luscious 86 pound Korean man the man
who lives off of nacho cheese and
cigarettes cheeto so you don't smoke in
I don't smoke I quit so you're wrong
there everything else he's correctly the
you bait now right I've ate by they've
now you've a I mean it's not exactly
it's not Nick it's not a [ __ ]
cigarette smoke though it's not start it
doesn't have all the chemicals in it yet
you know so I think I think something
that people I don't know don't really
know about is like with cigarettes
you got 499 chemicals in it and then
once you light it up and chemical
combustion happens it turns into like a
thousand chemicals right oh [ __ ] I don't
even know that yeah I just I just know
smoke so that's what you're putting into
your body whereas a vape has I think
four ingredients vegetable oil food
coloring nicotine and something else is
probably dangerous I don't know I'd I'll
be real with you sometimes like when
people vape and they smoke something
yeah I walk into the smoke on purpose
smells delicious yeah yeah I'm like some
I'm so sorry yeah you're welcome right
and thank you so much for blowing that
[ __ ] in my face and and that's a thing
with secondhand smoke even when I was
smoking I hated that [ __ ] it smells so
nasty after a while it starts to smell
sour there dude
and I think you don't realize how bad
you smell until you've quit for a period
of time right like you you're thinking
oh you know if I just kind of hold it
away from me you're not really gonna
smell yeah then you don't smell it on
yourself if you were like them you
really smell like cigarettes I'm like no
I don't what are you talking about but I
mean Who am I you got a [ __ ] immune
to that [ __ ] now right the smell so
you're right
that's the thing man like I never got
into smoking specifically because I
hated the way it smelled yeah and that's
all it took for me yeah
you know I will say that to my credit
that grown up ya ever smoked weed never
never smoked the cigarette and now
because I didn't understand how cool I
would look with it because I would have
looked [ __ ] cool I wouldn't I would
have been [ __ ] so badass
but the reason why I didn't was a very
basic reason I wasn't interested
and number two it smelled well that's
why you were youth pastor exactly
writing these kids in the right they're
confident in your choice I needed
someone like you in my life a hundred
percent also fat people already stink so
on top of being a fatty like that extra
[ __ ]
I don't need an extra cigarette smoke to
add to that right I mean that's the
thing man I got started when I was so
young because like you know smoking when
you were 11 bro I know what kind of
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] is that oh man your
parents must be proud of you piece of
[ __ ] they weren't too happy about that
but you know that smoking good find
exactly but that's the thing like in
Korean culture because like drinking and
smoking is so big I think that was not
as bad yeah but weed was a different
story when I got caught with my stash
with that that was like cuz you know two
Korean parents it's like no matter what
drug it is it's a [ __ ] the worst
thing ever you know yeah there's no
categories you know what I mean it's not
like weed is better than heroin right to
them it's in the same category yeah it's
Maya exactly yeah exactly it's all
clumped into one right like nebulous
category of bad right bad and the thing
that I didn't really get was like you
know what my my pops is like out in
South Central like it was around him all
the time yeah like everybody was smoking
[ __ ] joints around him yeah I was
like is it really that bad you know what
the funny [ __ ] is though I remember I
had this conversation my pops I was like
15 and I was like pops I promise you at
one point weed is gonna become illegal
yeah I don't know if it's gonna happen
soon or later but in our lifetime I
promise you it will how he's like that's
never gonna happen you know why cuz it's
Maya
oh dude everybody definites right right
this is a definite yeah has no benefit
whatsoever and then you know how you
know it's pretty much getting legalized
now a lot of place and then so I had
that conversation with him again say
pops do you remember when I told you
that it was gonna be legal what do you
think about it now because now the
government is pretty much saying
it can be used medicinally right and
innocent he goes oh we could open up a
shop not an opportunist uh he was like
no I still don't like it it's my oh my
god you know my dad like he feels that
way about it too but he's on the thing
I'm like you know my dad doesn't give a
[ __ ] anymore man yeah he's old he's like
man my dad said it like this I don't
want to deal with anything that's not
gonna make me happy anymore I'm old yeah
you know yeah it's like I'm not thinking
about that stuff anymore I'm going to
live my life as happy as possible right
I'm just gonna give you advice whether
you take it or not right go ahead yeah
and I just told him don't even give me
advice stop doing that [ __ ] stop yo you
know what my dad called me about today
talking funny like I'm chillin yeah and
I'm also learning to respond to my dad
and not a snippy way PS he's trying to
do things positively uh-huh but he
doesn't understand how obtrusive he
could be sometimes yeah because of stuff
that doesn't have anything to do with
him for example that calls me up he goes
hey did you know the name of your
channel change to genius brain changed
it a hundred percent he goes okay do you
know the value of what Dave is so comedy
is you threw that away and I told them I
was like dad when you go to work mmm and
you sell your weaves yeah your your the
way grease all that other stuff and
you're buying the stuff do I ever call
you a bagel hey yeah do you buy that
soup yeah I don't know [ __ ] about your
work you don't know [ __ ] about mine
leave it at right right right
he goes like you just threw away all
that value yeah my name still exists I'm
still alive you [ __ ]
wait did you change your Instagram
handle too is there still day no I would
have changed the genius brain but I
didn't because you actually can't change
your name after your verify oh it's hard
to get verified on Instagram okay so I
left it at that I changed my Twitter to
genius brain okay okay I know you're not
verified on Twitter no man come on man
is David so comedy right here I heard
they don't really verify anymore oh
really looks like a publicist gets it
done somebody at Twitter I see okay so
if you guys would like to verify me
please do because I say a lot of
offensive [ __ ] yeah so well going back
to that so the idea or the story behind
gene
spring oh yeah so genius brain if you
guys want to know which I don't even
think I introduced thanks for straight
right just went into it I don't want to
talk about ok so genius brain basically
what it is is it's me
it's a sarcastic thing I used to say to
people who thought they were really
smart like I was a good job genius brain
you know and I would say that
sarcastically because a lot of people
were just they were so hyped up about
letting people know how smart they are
yeah cuz they wanted to talk down to
people so I sarcastically would tell
them yeah call them a genius brain yeah
yeah and so I think that's very
reflective of Who I am as a person and
because I may not
a lot of people make on the exterior may
not see may have a lot to offer but
everybody has something to offer about
them everybody has a story to tell
right and it's not just like in this
podcast to you you if you've already
seen I haven't asked my YouTube
celebrity friends to really come on here
because you could get their stories on
their own platform right everybody has
an opinion and a story to share just
because you became a celebrity after the
fact you were a person that was born put
on your pants one leg at a time just
like everybody else and everybody has
those stories to they just don't have a
platform to tell it right so I just
wanted this to be a podcast that's
different from everybody else's we're
just I could bring anybody in I could
bring you in and we could have a
conversation to chop it up and it'd be
just as entertaining as if you had
Charlize Theron except for the fact that
I don't masturbate to her it's a
completely different thing that's how
genius brains started right and honestly
it just came in my head and I put it up
so so throw away everything else I just
said that back story stupid oh that
helps that you're able to have a
conversation cuz it would be some [ __ ]
if you brought somebody oh it's oh for
sure man like some people are
uncomfortable with telling certain parts
of their story because they're afraid of
the repercussions I don't care no I did
it for me man I feel like I'm not shy
about sharing you know intimate details
about my life because it's just the
human experience man like will want to
know right like this is we're living the
shared human experience yeah and if it
can help you somehow or if you can take
something away from it then by all means
take takedown right I gladly offer it to
you
bring the mic a little closer to you
okay yeah this thing keeps like you ugly
[Laughter]
bromide away from your face does too
right because we Robin yeah but my my
cake turn it away it's cuz I [ __ ] yours
up I got it I got every scratch yeah but
you know just I like the fact that
people have something to say right and I
want to give but to be honest with you
just because everybody has something to
say doesn't mean that they're really
great on this platform right what I'm
finding out there's gonna be a lot of
episodes I'm gonna have to throw away
and it's not because their story wasn't
interesting right it's because like when
I go over it even I'm dying when I'm
listening to it it's like [ __ ] dude man
yeah it's hard man I didn't realize that
this is a certain skill that you have to
have yeah you I feel like you're you
this guy talks to himself anyways
exactly I mean he's just giving me a
platform to for me to be able to do what
I would do anyway by myself no [ __ ]
psychopath that's what keeps me creative
guys so secret is you got to be a little
crazy a hundred percent man yo that's
what I've realized I'm never gonna be a
great actor because I don't do weird
[ __ ] dude like like I'm a weird person
yeah but I am like Kevin Spacey weird
right you know I think it's gusting
creep what did you think about that his
little YouTube clip of you know in did
you see that he had a YouTube clip dude
so he made all right so you know after
all this scandal and everything the
allegations right now he came out as
Frank Underwood so he's in his kitchen
dressed in civilian clothes he has an
apron on and he's doing things in the
kitchen talking his Frank Underwood this
is oh [ __ ] is Frank Underwood you
talking about [ __ ] house of cards
yeah from house of cards he's playing
his character and he's talking to the
audience in that character and he's like
almost indirectly talking about the
allegations against him through voice of
Frager Underwood saying like you know
did you jump to conclusions
you know it's things like that I was
like listen Frank other woods a [ __ ]
badass character in house of cards right
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] weird when I saw
that I was I was like okay
this just shows that yes you are a great
actor but you're all so [ __ ] weird
and said maybe at you and the [ __ ]
weirdo you yeah and you know it's it's
weird because I'm I don't know if it's
because I'm getting older now but I'm
starting listen Kevin Spacey I don't
know I don't know I wasn't there but
from you know you did some bad [ __ ] bro
you know Zed you [ __ ] baby touch it
that's what that's what I call
pedophiles by the way was it what was it
was a young person it was like like it I
think a teenage boy baby touch her you
baby [ __ ] touching [ __ ] but I'll put
it to you like this yeah I start to gain
empathy and I and even though a hundred
percent to blame and I'm disgusted with
what that person did I still as a human
being want to know how he got to that
Paul right right that's how did you get
there to the point and what his brother
said he was molested or something really
I didn't hear that I think his family
member came out saying that he was
molested and he actually had an
experience of him going through a child
like some sexual abuse as a child you
know what the crazy [ __ ] is yeah when
the the most recent I think like
criminal charges yeah were brought up
against him he chose that day to come
out as a homosexual can't Spacey
Kevin Spacey did so he was like trying
to no I think I bet that LGBTQ bit was
[ __ ] him are so exactly why gotta
create more problems right now more
[ __ ] baby touchin ass back in the
closet you son of a [ __ ] just like you
know what is going through the mind of
this person to think that you know it's
okay to be doing that and I think it's
fascinating man because no human being
us as human beings were not meant to be
celebrities or live the life of a
celebrity to have cameras constantly on
you true yeah invade your privacy all
the time to want something from you all
the time right what think about what
that does to you know somebody's psyche
right it it has to [ __ ] you there's no
way you don't get [ __ ] up from that
yeah and I think we see that a lot
especially
with child actors because they still are
not fully they haven't come into their
own identity yet you're still figuring
them out I was so sad when Britney
Spears [ __ ] shave your head man
I'll tell you you knew it was coming
though yeah but what I did I knew there
was something awful yeah was she married
what did she marry him yeah yeah Kevin
Federer I think Kevin Federline no
Federer no key Federline is Roger
Federer is yes but Kevin Roger Federer
it wasn't him yeah you accepted me yeah
yeah but that dude man yeah like when I
saw that when she was like this guy is
the man for me yeah my oh but even for
her she had like a dark past too right
you know whatever happened in that
Mickey Mouse Club a lot a few people
didn't come out too great yeah I mean
you know JT turned out fine he came out
of that I think Ryan Gosling came out of
that seemed like he kind of turned out
fine yeah yeah but you know it's a
number who was it
what's-her-name Miley Cyrus but she was
dizzy though yeah I think she was just
that Disney thing these Disney kids man
dude they [ __ ] breed stars man yeah
they breed stars like if you're a
childhood act or child actor for Disney
chances are you gonna be a [ __ ]
superstar you know I want somebody to
like assess what's going on in Miley
Cyrus's head because she for some reason
till this day still thinks that she
hasn't asked and I figure out why dude
it's so funny there was like this tweet
where she had her ass out and it was I
think it was like a album cover or
single cover with em and her ass is
supposed to be ood for mood somebody
tweeted why they should say Mead and my
ID is that [ __ ] was [ __ ] up that was
hilarious no Twitter is [ __ ] funny man
yeah I wish the [ __ ] out you know I try
not to get involved in like Twitter
conversations especially when it's like
don't don't literally charge or
something like that but sometimes dude I
just can't help myself man like cuz
[ __ ] reading the things that these
people are saying and they're trying to
pass it off as facts and like there
knowledgeable about this [ __ ] but it's
like did you even [ __ ] do any type of
research did you do any type of due
diligence to [ __ ] know what you're
talking about
oh they did it because yeah they're 12
years old for sure and sometimes man I
don't know dude
I guess it's sometimes I just got to be
in that mood where that it just pisses
me off in a special way where I got a
[ __ ] say something but it's rare now
I just on Twitter I just go there to
laugh at things because I sometimes I
don't want to get caught up in my
feelings okay
what's better though YouTube comments or
Twitter replies you to comments are way
worse yeah that's because the audience
is younger yeah yes at least with
Twitter the only thing you have our
words right I have to and you have to
realize too the majority is never going
to be the smartest group right if that
if it was true that a majority of people
in this world
yeah are quote-unquote genius brains
right right yeah then we wouldn't have
as much problems what stupid people pull
together more than smart people do smart
people kind of live off on their own
yeah and dumb people are the majority of
this world sure it's what it is men and
you know what the reason why we're
getting stupider is because now these
uneducated people are passing off false
like basically falsehoods for truths
because they have the platform to and
stupid people believe it exactly I mean
come on Flat Earth man you talk to Eddie
Bravo about that [ __ ] dude
that [ __ ] is all about
conspiracy I'm trying to figure out now
if people are into conspiracy simply
because it's fun or because if they
actually believe it or not and it's
getting to that point now where I'm not
sure right right not sure right I mean
they could just be really good trolls
you know what I'm true yeah they're just
doing it knowing that hey I'm gonna do
it could be like a social experiment
yeah I'm gonna sound confident in what I
say and come out with all these [ __ ]
facts but say it in a way where it seems
believable and I'm gonna see how many
people buy into this [ __ ] yeah I know
what I mean I mean I think there are
social experiments like that right yeah
and then when I hear like the art like
anti-vaxxers flat-earthers I'll never
understand the anti
vaccine thing it's like first of all get
your fun that's a child away from my
children no I'm not gonna put this one
youtuber on blast right this not she's
not a youtuber she's an Instagram person
oh I know put an influencer right very
beautiful young lady yeah however she
chooses not to vaccinate her dogs okay
she wants her dogs to play with other
dogs and it's it's the dumbest thing and
you know her reasoning for it was
because my dog is really small and I
don't think they'll survive the shots
okay dumb [ __ ] first of all yeah your
dog is not a new breed in existence
plenty of your dogs breed has gotten
vaccinations yeah what the [ __ ] are you
talking about right
get your zombie dog away from me now
immediately that's the prompt like date
like these people seem to think they're
unique you know like they're the
exceptions it's like no man there none
smallpox does not [ __ ] is not a problem
anymore because we have vaccinations for
it Yeah right it's so that people don't
[ __ ] get sick and pass it on to
somebody else yeah and you don't want to
[ __ ] get your kid vaccinate you just
making that [ __ ] kid's life miserable
you know you know I say like this man
everybody go and do your thing you don't
want to vaccinate your children go ahead
but keep your disease ready child away
from don't be mad if somebody yeah
exactly somebody says that [ __ ] yeah
right dude if you're deciding to go
again status quo then you have to expect
the backlash that comes with it so yeah
I mean like I'm not gonna sit here and
argue with it yeah your child you're
your choice go ahead yeah but yeah being
he responsible to the child I get little
Peter polio away from my child I mean
[ __ ] that [ __ ] dude that's what I'm
trying to deal with right now but
Twitter is not a space for you to really
have an in-depth comp you might find a
couple of gems here and there where
people will actually comprehensively
type out a point to you and you can go
back and forth with them most likely
that's not going to happen I've tried
that out now all I do is try to type
something that'll make that person as
angry as possible yeah that is what I do
I go they'll write something like well
you're wrong and I'm like that's funny
your mom is [ __ ] ugly that's I I'll
just respond in the most petty way dude
like I'm so terrible there was the
the other day there was a person so on
the genius brain that's right yeah
somebody wrote like hey yo you should
change that to blah blah cuz it's
completely illegible people can't read
it and throw back its cursive its
cursive yeah and so and I was laughing I
was like I was I was cracking up because
a few people are like I can't read it
and like the font can be you should
choose a different font type I was like
it's not a font type its cursive its
cursive I wasn't mad I was just cracking
up as I know maybe like a lot of like
younger people can't read cursive
anymore right if somebody got mad
they're like no we can read cursive it's
just you it was like the G looks like
this I can't read this and I just wrote
back I'm sorry you can't recursive it's
not a font type that's why it's funny
yeah you keep saying it's an artistic
font type it's cursive its oldest form
of writing in America of all time right
and so to me it was just funny I wasn't
mad about it but that person got mad
because they thought I was calling them
stupid yeah which they were right but
still you know like it was it you're
stupid but yes it's funny you know it's
not me mad at you because you can't read
it I'm saying it's funny that you
thought that cursive was a new font type
and an artist created yeah he didn't
create this one it's just cursive dude
yeah that's why I was laughing and I
thought it was hilarious that this
person wrote this whole spiel and then
he hashtag hashtag dominate humbly my
friends companies hashtag on to me and I
kind of thought about how's like dude
this guy's a [ __ ] weirdo dude why is
it that your opinion about this font
type should be so strong I should change
it for you specifically
[ __ ] false sense of entitlement
keyboard warriors whatever you want to
call it man and all I wrote it to was
like it's just an art piece it's not
it's not there the the point of the art
exactly is it work to be legible don't
just [ __ ] look at this is a whole
thing here you [ __ ] idiot yeah and
you know what I always thought learning
cursive was the most useless thing ever
but this proves let's be real man women
when in her life is cursive become
practically still writing cursive oh
really yeah well my handwriting is a mix
of cursive and regular you sir are a
gentleman and a scholar so when I like
remember I was working at the Men's
Wearhouse and I would have to fill out
this stuff for tuxedo [ __ ] and as I
would feel filling it out like wait yo
this girl she [ __ ] hurt my feelings a
little bit because I went to the back to
go check up on some [ __ ] and then she
was like who the [ __ ] wrote it curse at
this old-ass language who the [ __ ]
racist and I was in the back yo I teared
up a little bit she's like going in
about my hand right for like a solid
three minutes in the back just getting
blasted yeah Oh oh my god she's like
showing all her friends that's
interesting though man I didn't know you
still wrote in cursive yeah like it's
like a mix between cursive and not
that's crazy
it has nothing to do with being
stylistic it's just easier for me not to
lift up the pen oh yeah I just write
chicken scratch these sometimes like
I've seen your head right yeah
hieroglyphs yeah I like lick back on it
like what the [ __ ] that can you know
what the thing is like my mind is moving
too fast for my hand and then so like I
try to keep up with it and as a result I
try to write quick but it's just [ __ ]
just spear [ __ ] looks like alien
language dude like legit my deciphered
is if you were lost on an island and you
wrote save me on it yeah people would
think that was an alien invasion and
they wouldn't pick you up on the island
that's how illegible your [ __ ] is so
it's like oh yo that looks like some
[ __ ] crazy
it looks like alien ass right oh yo but
let's get into the topic today oh yeah
yo so um I don't know too much about
this but this is such a fascinating
thing that's been coming up so life time
dead is doing this series that's
currently on right now about the whole
r.kelly situation so if you guys know
most likely for sure a hundred percent
you guys know about this [ __ ] but our
Kelly is coming out and we were talking
about baby touches as a baby touches
like this dude has like this CD pass in
history and we've covered this before on
JK news but it's coming to light again
because lifetime is doing like I don't
know like a six-part series yeah
but three episodes are out and a lot of
this [ __ ] is coming out yeah for example
one of the biggest things that came out
is that our Kelly apparently had a
relationship with Aaliyah
the purest prettiest black girl the
history of rest in peace Aaliyah
know how you did it but you stuck a
rubber band around your waist in that
music video oh I gotta tell you I gotta
tell you something else Aaliyah
yeah hot exact safe way go buy her when
she was 14
apparently they had a legal marriage and
they she Adam I sure if she was forced
to but she was probably forced to marry
our Kelly yeah they'd light on the
documents I got a forest oh hey okay cuz
I was about to say what state allows
that you know to for a fourteen-year-old
to Wed Beijing but be like he was like
what 20-something at late 20s early 30s
at the youngest yes alright yeah but she
was 14 bro that's like okay first of all
the fact that it's alia hurts my soul
you know and the fact that somebody is
talented as our Kelly has to be such a
[ __ ] weird ass man like such a pervy
weird mother [ __ ] you know a lot of
there's a lot of people saying that that
did happen I get Leah's mom is denying
it because she doesn't want her name to
be tarnished of course and at this point
her name isn't tarnished because she was
a young girl that was coerced right by a
creepy baby toucher right and that's
that's the thing that's like I think she
should realize yeah is the bigger
picture your daughter's name is not
being alia forever will be an angel -
yeah yeah yeah are Kelly's name is being
tracked through the [ __ ] right and
rightfully so because sorry guys we had
to cut because the battery ran out on
the camera so we're gonna continue the
conversation from this point the battery
went out on the the camera because once
again this is a janky-ass production
yeah we're not a professional Dave you
shut the [ __ ] up anyways let's go back
to the baby touching yes baby touch yeah
but as I was saying Leah's mom is
thinking that her a Leah's name is going
to be tarnished but that's not the case
and I think there's a lot of good to be
done about taking this dude down and
happy he shouldn't be able to profit off
of his [ __ ] cuz he is using his his
power to just do some dirty ass [ __ ] man
and man you know who DJ Phantom is the
name rings a bell with I guess like he
was a part of his camp
and he's one of the people that has
separated away okay but most people that
have left here yeah still said nice
things about him yeah but DJ fans like
you I don't know about this [ __ ] about
him but I do [ __ ] this guy yeah yeah
yeah which is done rightfully so man
that mean why the [ __ ] would you you
know defend a guy who's done something
like that
there's been a lot of stuff talking
about his sex cult what about that [ __ ]
no no no that was the stuff prior to
this documentary that I didn't know
about just him being in a sex cult like
so he would like a lot of girls are
coming out saying that he has a sex cult
where they you know I think they're all
underneath or something yeah he would
quote coerce the Madu [ __ ] yeah there's
been other stuff coming out with in this
documentary saying that they remember
him [ __ ] like underage girls in the
bed yeah yeah Wow you know so yeah so
this dude is like a [ __ ] genuine
certified pedophile he's a pedophile
he's like he's just a creep dude yeah
yeah I can't listen to the are kelly
songs anymore like the way that i used
to that's what I mean that's what I'm
saying man it's like dude you you have
all this god-given talent man and and
people have loved your music yet you
can't I mean [ __ ] I don't know maybe has
a mental disorder or something I'm not
trying to justify what he did you know I
don't know why he does what he does why
he has these impulses or desires or
fantasies whatever it is yeah but yeah
it can't be excused
you know it's [ __ ] disgusting and
it's it there's no place for that for
that type of you know behavior in action
but dude I believe I can fly does not
mean the same to me no and no no no this
guy's complete so much I can't [ __ ] yo
man I've there's so many songs that has
that he has infiltrated into my spirit
that is not the same anymore right I
believe I can fly like that song right
yeah
which by the way Space Jam uh-huh
exactly you won't Space Jam for me you
[ __ ] me up you [ __ ] ruin the part of
our childhood our Kelly you stupid son
of a [ __ ] but you did have some good
kitchen
mama rolling that body got every man in
here wishing sipping on coke and rum
I'm like so wood I'm drunk it's the
freakin weekend everybody might they're
having some fun
hahaha you son of a [ __ ] I'll talk to
you are Kelly look at this man we were
just [ __ ] vibin and then we realized
reality set in and we realize you're
[ __ ] pedophile so you were talking
about young children in these songs you
know yeah dude I believe I can try
I believe I can touch them oh my
goodness spread those legs and fly away
you son of a [ __ ] you [ __ ] pervert
did yeah that's it's that's pretty
[ __ ] disgusting anybody that has
cornrows in the style of art Kelly you
need to shoot yourself with the [ __ ]
face absolutely son of a [ __ ] you know
it's funny because I think Z just
recently put up an art Kelly cover I was
like poor poor timing bro poor timing Z
I suggest that you immediately take that
[ __ ] down right now unless you also want
to be identified as a pedophile exactly
and a certain point you also had are
Kelly cornrows so that was the predator
though that was the prayer that was the
predator you know yeah I wish I had that
picture it's like it might probably one
of my old phones or something dude man
there's a lot of things that are coming
up about these no uh-uh
I'll talk about this you know I
adamantly defended bill [ __ ] this is
right when the and when the [ __ ] came
out I defended the [ __ ] out of him only
because yeah there weren't there wasn't
enough facts out yeah it was just like a
couple of allegations okay were you
defending him or were you being like
let's wait till you know before we make
judgment right let's make sure we know
all the information here yeah I think
that this point is just allegations yeah
right that would have been the smart
thing to do are you talking about jello
yeah there's no way jell-o pudding pop
is is is quay looting people right now
the man who didn't curse in his stand-up
and right Damned other black comedians
for cursed understand you telling me
right now he put his slimy dingdong
pudding pop on people I don't think so
and I defended the [ __ ] I was like boss
Oh out of nowhere so many years yeah I
bet you they want money yeah and I
thought that because I defended not Bill
Cosby the person I was defending Bill
Cosby as in Cleef Heathcliff Huxtable
but right
the TV show guy I fell in love with
right right and I forgot to separate
that persona from the actual human right
and I didn't know what I was doing which
is hard in a lot of cases when somebody
becomes so iconic for a certain ya know
what I mean he was actually one of the
biggest reasons I decided to go into
comedy man cuz I to me The Cosby Show is
the best sitcom hands-down for me you
know the way above Fresh Prince of
bel-air around everything else right The
Cosby Show moulded a huge part of my
life yeah yeah The Cosby Show yeah also
even molded the type of woman that I
wanted to be with yeah yeah now let me
ask you this then though when something
like that happens to somebody that
iconic like Bill Cosby Yeah right are
his past work now deemed irrelevant and
something that shouldn't be considered
because that's his character did a lot
of good right the person you could dam
and condemn them as much as you want
yeah but just because and I think a lot
of people like [ __ ] The Cosby Show let's
take it out because there's a lot of
hurt and the guys it's putting money in
his pocket yeah yeah yeah yes you know I
get that part too yeah
but The Cosby Show was a show that
showed a family of color that didn't
have to be well yo what's up what's
happening you know I mean what's poppin
you know right it was it was a doctor a
physician yeah that lived on the East
Coast right with a wife who was working
super hard and was becoming a partner in
a law firm yeah you know what I mean
yeah but they didn't lose their cultural
that cultural [ __ ] that they had to
admit that death flavor you don't say
but yeah it showed a color family in a
different light yeah and it showed real
humor dude that first episode of The
Cosby Show is [ __ ] hilarious yeah the
very first episode is where uh his son
Theo comes in yeah and it's like that
class a big word kid is not doing well
in school he's [ __ ] up his rooms
dirty and he looks at his dad and he
goes dad I know you want me to be really
smart da da da da however how can you
can't just love me for who I am and in
the classic like white American thing
you would hear the the music come on
parent with the [ __ ] fuzzy shirt
fuzzy sweater at the collar and the tie
comes on it puts his hand on the the son
shoulder and says yes son I was wrong
yeah but Bill Cosby says feel that is
the dumbest thing I've ever heard of my
life you lazy PA and that was some real
[ __ ] right that was hilarious right and
that's what I loved about the show yeah
so I it's like this to it I and I want
people yeah you know you guys could
choose to do it I know who the [ __ ]
cares you Denis and everybody's
individual I want Michael Jackson yeah
yeah that's it's tough man because like
Michael is the the Prince of pop Brea I
mean he made so many [ __ ] classic hits
and you know what I still do listen to
Michael Jackson to this day you know I
still do enjoy his music but it's you
know it's a tricky thing man when you're
trying to separate the criminal right
from this creative genius right I heard
or I read it was on Fox yeah I think his
ex-wife uh-huh
well I guess I key like physically
abused too or whatever he's actually
abuse yeah it came out said a lot of
things about him too yeah she started
off as a young background dancer from he
got married or whatever yeah but I guess
our Kelly wrote correct me if I'm wrong
uh-huh you were not alone for Michael
Jackson really yeah and he said that
that song was for her Wow
yeah so that songs room for me too yeah
yeah wow that's some [ __ ] look at that
dude that is [ __ ] couple of baby
touches together you're writing a song
but you know what like I think it's
pretty known that Michael Jackson was
abused you know as a kid all right man
yeah and again this is not to excuse the
behavior but to just give some context
like clearly this guy had some mental
issues you know whether it's a mental
illness or whatever the case and that
that's a serious thing you know yeah
there's in America there's a big taboo
around like talking about mental issues
right seeing it there I mean it's
getting better definitely has gotten
better over time but that's real I mean
I met a kid man who was schizophrenic
right I didn't know
so this happened on my parents place
right my my mom told me uh one of the
our neighbors kids was acting out and I
was like what do you mean he's like he
he started to like get a little
aggressive and like Vai I was like in
what weight ya know like well he'll say
stuff and then like he'll like come over
to our yard and so I was like oh hell
like for me so family beat up a
schizophrenic tape no no I was about to
but ya know like when it comes to family
I mean that's you don't cross that line
we draw that line yeah yeah yeah liya
I happen to be home I visited my parents
one day and then I'm there and then I
hear like this pounding at the door
right now I'm like what the [ __ ] like
it's like a violent pound like I open
the [ __ ] door tight pound right I
open the door and it's this kid and I'm
like hey man what the [ __ ] you pounding
on my door like that for right I like a
for the record you've been scaring my
mom I mean you cut that [ __ ] out I don't
know what the [ __ ] wrong with you yeah
I'll cut that [ __ ] out now remember I
don't know daddy schizophrenic at this
point I just think he's yeah just being
weird and then he asked me you're the
[ __ ] hacker right I was so confused
like hacker I mean he's like you're the
hacker who hacked into my computer and
said you're gonna [ __ ] me in the ass I
said whoa bro right now you [ __ ] are
saying some fighting words man now you
now you saying yeah I was like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about homophobe how
dare you
no but long story short it went on that
path and then I was getting pretty
[ __ ] pissed right and I was about to
hit this guy but then his other brother
came and stepped in and he took him away
and then he put him in the house and it
came to me yeah he's like hey I'm really
sorry about that he's having some pretty
bad schizophrenic episode I was like oh
[ __ ] your brother schizophrenic he's
like yeah you know like he's we're gonna
you know send to get some treatment the
pills aren't really working and yo real
[ __ ] bro one of the cuz I was cool with
like his brother and his friends right
one of it their friends told me dude
like when they sent him off finally yeah
he [ __ ] cornered his mom and was
trying to rape her oh yeah in the
[ __ ] house that's what ultimately was
the last straw like right we're sending
him a hold was he he was like 17 holy
[ __ ] yeah oh my god yeah I feel so bad
for the mom yeah I mean dude but the mom
wasn't all there either she was like she
had a lot of weird things - oh [ __ ]
so that's what I'm saying man like I
don't know about these people's life
stories man like it's it's kind of wild
yeah man it's [ __ ] like like we're
talking about they have no connection to
reality they're living in this alternate
world where stories and characters are
made up in their head they're hearing
these voices and [ __ ] but that's real to
them you know what yeah there's no way I
could understand that no possible way
even though I am I am crazy and I talk
to myself not in them yeah I do that too
though people don't understand I'm
writing scripts out loud though that's
what I'm doing yeah so you know these
mental issues man it's a serious serious
thing and it affects people in a lot of
different ways uh-huh you know some
unfortunately sometimes people who are
in the limelight who are talented who
are beloved do these fucked-up things
yeah right and again it's not to excuse
the behavior you know but at least
there's some sort of understanding to
why maybe why this person did what they
did
you know yeah like it's something that's
beyond our understanding and bottom line
is they need some [ __ ] help they need
some treatment you know but conversely
it's all so [ __ ] great when people
you love like mr. Rogers everybody
confers what you thought you know I was
so disappointed though when I found out
there was this rumor going about it yeah
it was a military sniper really why he
was wearing his long swears because he
was hot he was hiding his tattoos I was
like dude mr. Rogers was like sitting on
top of a [ __ ] sand dune going yeah
Jupe like I literally thought the mess
what that was and then I found out you
know that was just a [ __ ] you sons of
[ __ ]
I really wanted that to be true dude I
wanted mr. Rogers to just be like that
would make it more bad
making my tutu train noises my mother
[ __ ] down dude choo-choo-choo
[ __ ] Oh Bobo black black correct
but you know a guy like him time and
time again man like all the stories that
come out about him it just confirms like
what you thought you know it doesn't
just an act
can i I'm gonna tell you guys a very
personal story right now huh when I was
working at the Men's Wearhouse yeah
that's when I found out that mr. Rogers
passed away
uh-huh and I didn't realize how much
that dude meant to me in my childhood
right until he passed the right right I
was driving and on the radio they
announced that he passed away yeah oh
[ __ ] mr. Rogers died and I was driving
driving driving yeah dude I don't know
where I started tearing up okay what the
[ __ ] am i tearing up yeah mr. Rogers
right right
and I just like started like I would say
balling yes tears yeah coming down yeah
yeah figure out why yeah and I remember
I was talking to my mom so after that
you know after I whatever stop being you
know super hyper emotional I guess my
mom yeah as you remember who mr. Rogers
she with all he loved mr. Rogers used to
watch all the time really
I just watched mr. Rogers and Al Abbar
Burton on Reading Rainbow okay yeah yeah
that's not my first introduction to that
yeah and it you know to go even further
into that I don't know if you guys will
[ __ ] believe this or not so I I was
on Facebook yeah and there was his clip
of mr. Rogers speaking in court
uh-huh to keep public television alive
oh I remember that yeah saw that yeah I
did yeah I saw this [ __ ] I should have
be bawling again for her like I could
not stop crying dude yeah and it was how
passionate he was yeah children's
self-esteem and self-worth right right
well something when I watched that yeah
clicked in me super [ __ ] harness
actually something that I talk about
what I travel to colleges yeah I joke
about my self-esteem a lot yeah and what
I mean by that is that there's a lot of
people who have gone through something
where I think as a youth they've had
suicidal thoughts before I can honestly
say as a youth I never had suicidal
thoughts Wow never once my life well and
one of the things that clicked hard is
if you watch that if you guys go and you
have free time and you watch that
Facebook clip of talking
yeah he talks about something that he
says I can't remember it verbatim right
now but it has to do along the lines
with how special you are
yes and I I do remember that how
important yeah yeah and I didn't even
know yes is prior to be witty to that
right but what he said in that is
exactly what I say when I go on these
college show yeah yeah yeah and I was
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] my identity yeah
and my important life is based off of
everything I learned from this write on
public television show and he was
expressing how important his show was
and how important public television yeah
yeah and I'm [ __ ] proof of that yeah
yeah I guarantee you yeah he was a huge
I mean obviously my family my parents
whatever you know that's yeah that's
there too not whatever but you know but
that was such a huge part of my life
yeah like those little seeds get planted
yeah however small or meniscal you think
that it is yeah it gets planted and when
I heard it clicked hard baby cry even
harder dude I was like son of a [ __ ]
dude I was like he was the dude yeah
that's planted that seed in my head yeah
and what I say to people when I go on
these college shows when they asked me
to do some motivational speaking I
always say this there's there's
something that everybody always says to
me they go hey I want to do what you do
which is what I do right because I want
to feel important yeah I want to I feel
like I I want to feel special but I feel
like I don't have anything important say
and I always tell people the same thing
is like it's not the fact that you don't
have anything important to say or you
haven't got that or something unique
yeah it's the fact that you don't
believe it is that it's based on the
fact that you don't believe that you
have a unique voice for the moment that
you're born to the day that you die
there will never be another you that is
a fact that is a that is not an opinion
it is a [ __ ] right every experience
that you've had may have been similar to
somebody else's but from the moment that
you're born your existence is unique
that is important but it's your job to
figure out what makes it special
yeah and that's what people don't do
yeah yeah so when you have a
conversation with me and you Saviour's
and you say to me I am NOT special you
are [ __ ] special problem is you
probably have
taking the time to invest in yourself to
figure out what makes you you
so that's your responsibility it's not
that life failed you and gave you a
boring-ass life yeah it was your choice
to be unobserved about it absolutely and
you know what I always say to men is
when you're born into this world the
only thing promised to you is death
nothing else not even family not even
friends not a good job not a great
partner nothing is promised you
everything is a [ __ ] bonus right yeah
but within that if you want something
you got to work for it you don't [ __ ]
feel entitled to it yeah word for it and
earn that [ __ ] right but do it with
realistic expectations yeah no don't
think because I'm gonna [ __ ] work
hard I should be a [ __ ] millionaire
ya know work hard to see results right
yeah if you see results that's what you
get that's the labor of your hard work
yeah you know what I mean but just
because it's not in line with these
false expectations you set for yourself
that maybe stems from entitlement that
maybe stems from delusion I don't know
but don't be disappointed because you're
setting yourself up for disappointment
then yeah you know what I mean and a guy
like mr. Rogers man I feel like when
somebody is just has this unadulterated
pure type of love and passion for what
it is they do and say education in jazz
yes to make the world a better place for
the future he is and he is anti r.kelly
dude he thought it'd be opposite r.kelly
you could possibly be much children in a
different way exactly a most beautiful
way that's right yeah he's anti baby
touchy there you go it's a deal oh it
all comes together yeah yeah - I didn't
realize that dude mr. Rodgers also an R
R Kelly Robert Kelly mr. Rogers yeah
dude Wow if we wrote a Bible right now
Satan would be mr. [ __ ] up back the [ __ ]
that would be R Kelly yeah and then
Jesus right he's mr. Rogers yes let's
start on that book tonight I'm gonna
write my own version of the Bible
and I'm writing that [ __ ] blog dude
yeah that's crazy as a [ __ ] trip and
his song remix also had keeping that
choo-choo which is a trade but mr.
Rodgers yo man is something your [ __ ]
dude this is next-level she's no flat
earth is real bro yeah he's woke right
now there you go whatever I'm so [ __ ]
this they don't even understand you're
not even on my level right now dude
yo that's what I just blew my own
[ __ ] mind dude I know as and that's
like [ __ ] that happened completely
randomly we went off on it a hundred
percent dude then I have to end the
podcast right now because it's perfectly
does not get better than that
I'm not doing [ __ ] dude that's another
episode of the genius brain podcast
thank you guys for tuning in I will
catch you all another time see you soon
stay beautiful I love you so much don't
be a narc leb mr. rat these guys